Vsauce. Today on my subway ride into work I
earned the very final star I needed in
Angry Birds.
But I know what you're thinking.
"Michael, I don't care. I want things I can do
online now, gosh!"
DONG. Let's begin
with Leanback. That's right, there's a
brand new episode of Vsauce Leanback
out today.
It's a television-length playlist
full of - this week - optical illusions.
You can start it by clicking the link
at the very top of this video's description.
'Idotidot2' pointed me to How Many
Of Me, where you can type in your name and find
out how many people in the US
have your same name. Now, if you wanna two games at
once, be like 'tjockislol'
and become Mario until you press the
spacebar and begin
Tetris to strategically help Mario.
Want more pep? Well, be like 'DEEMEMH' and use GoBarbra.com
to make Duck Sauce's song about whatever you want. For instance:
"I'm watching DONG."
Too fast? Slow down with 'Erinbunny1's' reminder
of this oldie
in B-flat. Every embedded video is in the
same key,
so you can pick and choose which ones to
bring in
and when. 'Yorkerbird434' turns up the
violence with a Whack Rebecca Black game
built like YouTube.
Throw her for points and if you kinda feel bad or
weird, don't work. 'MochaholicPuppy' thinks you're a licensed toy
and animal psychologist. This site let's you
evaluate toys and even administer
drugs.
Last week I showed off a game that let's
you compose music with dots
and 'sofusser' created an entire Vsauce symphony.
'Sofusser' also made some pretty sweet
designs on World of Text, so
check them out.
Last week I also talked about some work
from Mister
Doob. 'Gaigaigoo' said whoa, whoa, whoa,
there's more Stevens.
And there is. Mr. Doob has made a lot
of awesome things, like this page you can
drag images into
right from your computer and then watch them warp and twist.
Click to cause a whole new
transformation. He also built a sweet
browser-based fullscreen cloud simulator
you can fly through by moving your
cursor around.
But what your browser really needs is
balls and he brought those too.
This site of his gives you balls you can pick
up and throw, but you can also grab the actual
browser window
and give it a shake.
I leave you with something very special.
This link will take you to a video
were you can listen to what's known as
the IMG
montage music in its entirety. You now
have the power to make anything in your
life
an instant IMG montage. Of course what you
really want to do
is watch today's new episode of Vsauce Leanback all
about optical illusions sourced from all
over YouTube.
It's a really cool collection and I'm having a lot of fun making them, so check it out.
And as always,
thanks for watching.